Whenever Pvt. Pyle f---s
up, I will not punish him!
I will punish all of you!
Yep, there we go.
The DI and the drill sergeant
is going to definitely
dole out punishment as a mass punishment.
I'm Command Sgt. Maj.,
retired, Lamont Christian.
I served about 11 years
as a drill sergeant,
and then as a senior
leader in organizations
that conducted basic combat training.
Today we're going to be
looking at boot-camp scenes
and seeing how realistic they are.
Forrest: And always answer
every question with,
"Yes, drill sergeant."
Drill sergeant: Is that clear?!
Yes, drill sergeant!
The standard for responding
to a drill sergeant
is, "Yes, drill sergeant,"
"No, drill sergeant,"
and if it has to have
an affirmative response,
then the whole platoon
will sound just like that.
Done, drill sergeant!
Jesus H. Christ!
This is a new company record.
The drill sergeant was so
impressed because, you know,
in the early part of training,
it's a challenge for somebody
who perhaps has not
handled a weapon before,
what we would call weapons training,
to be able to take that weapon
apart, put it back together,
and do what you saw Forrest do there,
which was that functions check.
What your hope is as
a DI or drill sergeant
is that everybody in there
can do it like Forrest.
Shrimp and potatoes, shrimp burger.
What's funny is when
they're in there with them
with toothbrushes, that's
something of the past.
There was times where, you know,
you'd give a recruit scissors
and say, "Go cut the grass."
They're fostering this environment
of working together as a team,
which you saw with the weapons training,
which is what I call mindless repetition.
Just do it over and over and over again
until you get it right.
That has the same training
effect that this used to have.
The approach that the
drill sergeant had in here
was very, very common
for that time period,
during the Vietnam War.
So that's about a nine.
Pick it up! Move it! Move it!
I want to see some fire here!
When you look at obstacle courses,
usually in boot camp, you'll
go through them twice.
Obstacle courses are really designed
to find your upper-body strength
and also determine your endurance,
and so it may even test
your fear of heights,
fear of darkness, and then
you get to actually experience
the teamwork, helping each other.
You saw that a couple of times in there.
And definitely that screaming and yelling.
Often we call it simulating
battlefield conditions.
Drill sergeant: Create a loop.
This is the rabbit hole.
The rabbit comes out of his hole.
What is interesting is
ropes and knot tying
is no longer taught in basic training.
It is in Ranger School, though.
You're actually tested
in the mountain phase.
As things change over time,
there's certain requirements
that the leaders think that people need
upon finishing basic training.
This is to be your lover,
your mistress, your concubine,
perhaps the only thing in
life you'll ever truly love.
That's one of those things, again,
that you get from TV in Hollywood where
we place all of this level
of intimacy with our weapon.
Now, granted, it is an
intimate relationship
because you really want to be
confident with that weapon.
So taking it apart, putting it together
almost to the point where you
can do it blindfolded, right?
Talk about it in a way
that might be sexual,
that's kind of a Hollywood
thing that happens.
Oh, I'm sorry, sergeant.
I can't touch a gun.
For that time period, being World War II,
being a conscientious objector
was going to definitely be a challenge
for the leadership here.
This guy particularly is Desmond Doss.
He was actually a Medal
of Honor recipient,
and he didn't have to
carry a weapon to do it.
I would definitely say
this was a nine on realism.
Drill instructor: Can't
think when I'm giving you
a few love taps?
How the f--- are you
going to fire your rifle
when grenades are going off in your face?
Unfortunately, what we wind
up running into a lot of times
is drill sergeants or DIs like this one
that will touch and grab by the throat.
That was familiar in other DI movies.
Touching recruits in
training is unacceptable.
Always has been.
Sir, I got lost on the
way to college, sir!
That's exactly why, right there.
The open door that I could do even more,
and it turns to him slamming
the kid's head into a wall,
and that's why it's unacceptable.
Because where do you draw the line?
Them paintball bullets, they hurt?
Oh, s---!
Paintball is something,
as you notice there,
it was pretty painful.
That guy is going to
learn a valuable lesson
not to put himself in a window
if he's going to engage.
And so that's why paintball Simunitions,
is kind of what we call it,
is very, very useful in
the training environment.
Drill sergeant: The sounds
that you are hearing
are live rounds.
You will get the fear out of you.
Keep moving! Keep your head down!
Yeah, that's a trainer, a sergeant,
a leader's worst nightmare,
is to have somebody in
training lose their life.
Shooting the rounds over their head,
we actually do that, and
we also do it at night,
but the conditions are totally different.
The guns are raised up a whole lot higher,
and it's what we call a safe surface zone.
So even if you stood up
or jumped up and down,
it's almost 20 feet above
the heads of the individuals.
And, again, this tragedy right here,
as unfortunate as it is, it does happen
when those things are not adhered to.
For a boot-camp movie,
it's probably about a five.
Rusty bayonet, Liebgott.
Now, thanks to these men
and their infractions,
every man in the company who
had a weekend pass has lost it.
This is pretty neat,
because I actually served
as the command sergeant
major for this unit.
For the 2nd Battalion, 506th
Parachute Infantry Regiment
out of the 101st Airborne.
This right here is Easy Company
and their preparation for World War II.
During that time period in our military,
not many people were married, right?
And everybody was always looking for
a two-day or a three-day pass.
The stuff that they're being inspected on,
like this parade-level stuff,
and they're out there in combat gear,
I could see where he's going
with trying to instill discipline.
Just, I'm sure morale
is not going to be too high much longer.
Platoon: Stand alone! Stand alone!
Sobel: Do not help that man!
Do not help that man!
We ran this mountain a couple of times.
Currahee Mountain.
Yeah, it's no joke.
What I noticed here though, you know,
he was telling them to leave that guy.
Not leaving a fallen comrade,
that was part of the warrior ethos.
And never quitting.
So when you tie that together
in today's modern military,
leaving somebody behind would be something
that we wouldn't do.
That would be a 10 for
running up that hill.
And for World War II,
it'd probably be about a eight in realism.
Drill sergeant: "Yes,
drill sergeant, and "No,
drill sergeant." Do I make myself clear?
Recruits: Yes, drill sergeant!
You get them in the barber
chair, spin them around,
they had no hair.
Like, that's even part of a
military cadence sometimes.
The males, anyway, are
getting their hair cut
where they cut it all the way down.
Female recruits are not required.
And believe it or not,
it's a health and hygiene issue, right?
Because you get people that
come from all walks of life,
and so you don't know necessarily
if they have, like, head lice
or any other type of issues
underneath all the hair.
Cherry: Next we got
about 100 f---ing shots.
You just get shots until you
get all the way to the end
and you're completely inoculated
against every disease known to man, right?
Execute.
Drill sergeant: Move, goddamn
it! Move! Let's go, move!
The difference that I could
see so far in this scene is
they have them all
taking their clothes off
in an open room or an open bay.
It wouldn't be done that
way at what they call
a military entrance processing
station, or the MEPS.
All military members go through there,
and there's no drill sergeants there.
It's just a staff of military personnel,
administrators, doctors, counselors,
because what they're doing
is they're determining
whether or not you're fit to train.
Cherry: They had us strip
down to our underwear
and duckwalk the circuit of a big room.
Oh, yeah, duckwalking.
I remember the first time I did that.
I was like, "What in the world?"
They have you walk from one
side of the room to the other,
and the doctor is looking
for your bone structure,
your musculoskeletal development,
if you're flat-footed, also
just your mobility and agility.
But yeah, you definitely
wouldn't be in a room like that
full of other people. Be hard to assess.
I would have to say it's
about a four, right?
Because that's not necessarily
how that whole indoctrination process
would happen with the drill sergeants.
If you survive recruit
training, you will be a weapon.
You will be a minister
of death praying for war.
So far this is looking pretty good.
Because in the DIs in the Marine Corps,
they actually have a script.
They say, "You'll sit up
straight and look at me!"
So while the difference in the titles,
the drill instructor was
tied into the Marine Corps.
Drill sergeants came
into play for the Army.
And the interaction in the
first part of boot camp
is always going to be what
we call total control.
Everywhere you look,
there's going to be some DI
or drill sergeant
ensuring that the training
that has been given is being reinforced.
And so when you see R. Lee
Ermey walking around in the bay,
he's doing exactly what a DI would do.
He actually was a drill
sergeant, as a matter of fact.
He served several years during
the Vietnam War as a DI.
You maggots understand that?
Sir, yes, sir!
Bulls---! Can't hear you!
If you notice, the DI
is constantly yelling,
and it's not because they
like yelling at individuals,
it's just so they don't have to repeat
the same commands over and over.
So if you have a recruit
on one end of the bay,
he or she is going to
hear the instructions
all the way on the other end of the bay.
5-foot-9, I didn't know
they stacked s--- that high.
You trying to squeeze an
inch in on me somewhere? Huh?
Another thing that you
often see in these movies
and TV shows is the DI
or the drill sergeant
doing a lot of cursing and swearing.
Cursing and swearing is not
something that is acceptable,
but it does happen.
For that Vietnam era,
that's pretty realistic.
Now you have people who are
deciding to serve their country,
and it's a different view.
I was part of the committee
that created the change,
what we called shock and awe,
commonly called a shark attack,
as opposed to this fallacy, which was
we have to break them down
in order to build them up,
and focus more on the teamwork.
And so that's what The 100
Yards was designed to do.
Day one, here's a challenge.
Pop that blister!
Lamont: Mm-hmm.
Part of that indoctrination
when the DI comes in
is the wellness of the
trainees or the recruits,
and so they have to inspect the feet,
inspect the hands,
and make sure that there's no open sores.
What the f--- is that?
What is that, Pvt. Pyle?
Sir, a jelly doughnut, sir!
We've gone away from footlockers
and modularized most of
the equipment in the bay.
So you wouldn't necessarily
have a footlocker in the bay,
and he definitely wouldn't be standing
on the equipment like that.
They have this term in the
Army they call "toe the line,"
and that's where they actually
stand next to the line
so that they can do that inspection.
From now on, whenever Pvt. Pyle f---s up,
I will not punish him.
I will punish all of you!
Yep, there we go.
Especially in the beginning
phases of boot camp,
the DI and the drill sergeant
is going to definitely dole out punishment
as a mass punishment, even
though one person may mess up.
This opportunity for
somebody to have looked
and held Pyle accountable
for that doughnut was missed,
and that's what the DI is reinforcing.
We'll hold each other accountable.
I would have to say it was probably
about a nine for that era.
If we're talking in today's terms,
it'd probably be about a seven in realism.
We are going to win this war
because we have the best men.
When they were standing in formation
and the leader stopped and
kind of looked at this guy
and he looks like a middle-school kid,
there was actually a guy named Flaherty.
This guy was 4 feet 9 inches,
and they called him The Giant Killer
because of all the different exploits
that he did during Vietnam.
And he was smaller than Rogers was, right?
Nobody's got that flag in 17 years!
Yo, the smallest guy in the formation
wound up coming up with
the plan of success.
In the basic-training environment,
you probably wouldn't have
that type of situation
placed on a trainee or a recruit.
That's some
special-missions-type unit stuff
that's going on there where
an assessment is being done, right?
Because they want to know if
you have a special skill set.
What they were actually
doing in the training
would not necessarily be something
that you would see in recruit training.
So I'm going to give it a five.
Left! Face!
Yeah, that's the campaign hat
or the famous drill sergeant hat.
I just happen to have mine with me,
and, you know, there's
distinct headgear that is worn
by the male drill sergeants in the Army,
but then also by the male and
female DIs in the Marines.
What's unique is, while all the branches
except the Navy have some
form of a campaign hat,
the Army still has a separate hat
for the female drill sergeant.
It's called a bush hat.
A-left, a-left, right, left.
♪ There she was just
walking down the street ♪
♪ Singing do wah diddy
diddy dum diddy do ♪
That part where the one
character starts singing
that diddy bop, it's
interesting that most cadences,
that's actually where
they come from, right?
Popular tunes, R&B music, I
mean, even nursery rhymes.
Even my own voice has
been tapped into a cadence
in the Gatorade commercial
singing the hard work cadence.
♪ Work, work ♪
♪ Hard work ♪
So these guys, they're just, you know,
jumping in on a bandwagon,
throwing in the diddy bop
in there at the same time.
Razzle dazzle!
Hut, two, three, four!
Yeah, that ain't happening.
However, in the Army,
in what we call the advanced
individual training,
which, those periods of
training go from six weeks
to six months, maybe even a year,
drill and ceremony
competitions are usually used
to continue to motivate those individuals
that have the longer periods of training.
But not as likely in a
basic combat training
because we're focusing on
shooting, moving, communicating,
and treating yourself and
others on the battlefield.
I'd have to say a four.
Locate a wounded soldier,
represented by a dummy.
You must then transport him to
the emergency field hospital.
There's a lot going on there so far.
When it started out, it
definitely was something
that you would see in recruit training.
You know, a lot of female leaders now
are in positions of senior leadership,
something that hadn't
occurred over many years,
until the military had
started really opening up
the ranks of the infantry
to our female leaders.
An aggressor team will
be trying to stop you.
They are all awaiting ranger training
and can't wait to capture you.
Based on what the information
and the instructions they were given,
it's actually an advanced
individual training.
You know, medical training.
They're not going to be
as complex with a mission
that would go that deep,
and that was evident
when I saw them in the river there,
because the risk for, you
know, perhaps somebody drowning
or something else with
all that equipment on,
then not too many people
are going to want to
put a recruit in that type of environment.
Again, the risk factors
wouldn't be something
that you'd see in recruit training,
but definitely something
very similar challenging-wise
as far as the military's concerned.
You know, Marines have a Crucible,
and the Army has this
thing called The Forge.
Very similar, in the final
test of all of the training
that they receive during
the recruit training.
And there are medical lanes
where they might have to treat
a casualty or transport a
casualty, like you saw here,
to really see if all of the training
has actually reached the
point where they are confident
that these individuals can leave
and go to their next assignment.
I have to give that a
five as far as realism.
♪ Casey Jones was a son of a b---- ♪
Hazing is something that,
again, has never been accepted,
but it happens.
This is depicting an
environment where there's still
initial entry training or
initial military training,
but it's Officer Candidate School.
Typically, officer candidates
are a little bit more mature,
have either been in the
military for quite some time
and reached enlisted ranks.
There's levels of hazing
that may be more acceptable
in that environment
versus in the recruit training.
So there was a mandate
that provided leadership
across all of the branches to come up with
progressive ways, if you would,
in order to attack and
get in front of hazing.
And so whether it was
reporting, such as in the Army,
you know, Not in My Squad,
to place accountability
not just on leadership, but on each other.
No, sir!
Drill sergeant: DOR!
I ain't gonna quit!
Right, then you can forget it!
You're out!
Don't you do it!
There's about two or three
layers of checks and balances
so that you don't have that
rogue DI or rogue drill sergeant
who might take something personal
like it looks like in this clip.
Because of the flexibility and the things
that take place in the
Officer Candidate School
versus what happens in recruit training
for initial entry training,
I would say that it's
probably about a seven.
All right, Shirley, you can drop them now.
Weight training has always been something
that's important in the military
to be able to carry your body weight.
And in some cases, you
might have to lift or carry
or drag somebody else.
The sand buckets and them
using them for weights,
a lot less expensive than
buying weights for every Marine.
But then they get the same
physical exercise out of it.
Drill instructor: See the jab? Outside?
Right into the body once again.
Working with the blade.
They were doing combatives,
right, with the pugils,
and then the drill instructor
was showing them with the
knife close-quarter combat,
because every Marine, every soldier,
every person that joins the military
is a fighter first, right?
And so pugil stick training
is one of those ways
that that confidence is
instilled in the individual
and their ability to stand their ground.
And it's also fun to look at.
I would say it's about a seven.
My favorite drill instructor was Jack Webb
in the movie "The D.I."
It actually shows
both sides of the drill instructor's life.
What does he do in the evenings
after he's away from the bay squad?
If you enjoyed this video,
why not click on this video above?